the whole joy of joy holiest of holies
splendor of splendor oh oh uh as I'm
sure you will know the trailer for the
Sonic the Hedgehog movie just throughout
the other day and it is everything I was
hoping it would be in so much less this
is something I don't usually do like I
don't really do trailer reactions
because it's like it's a trailer I mean
it's like there's good trailers and bad
trailers I actually really love trailers
and analyzing what works about them and
stuff but it's like you can't judge a
movie until it comes out really there's
some amazing trailers for awful movies
oh there's some awful the trailers for
great movies but this one this trailers
a work of art okay like everyone is
really hating on this understandably so
but I really think we're looking at this
from the wrong mindset this trailer is
just so many beautiful levels of awful
and terrible that it's it doesn't seem
real does it I mean we always make jokes
like Aladdin looks like a fake movie or
like that Ghostbuster reboot that looks
like a fake movie but this really really
looks like a fake just doesn't look real
and the choices they make it aren't so
spectacular like okay so I don't really
do trailer reactions where you film
someone reacting to someone cuz my
reactions believe it or not are kind of
boring like when I see when we do the
first viewings like where we're kind of
paid to be on we have to make jokes so
we'll be a little bit more lively
watching it but a trailer I mean I don't
I although probably like a lot of you I
just kind of watch it and let it sink in
might laugh or you know or something
like then that's about it I'm actually a
very boring person to watch a trailer
with you know I might give my thought at
the end like that looks good or
something but this I so wish I was
recording my reaction to this I mean
just the whole time like I'm gonna try
and just recreate the face I had I don't
even know what that looks like that's
just the face I had
beautiful uh everything I heard about
this movie I like you know I always
heard him passing cuz he okay quick
quick sum up I I like Sonic the Hedgehog
play that when I was a kid I liked the
Saturday morning cartoon even that like
weird one with like the goofy
backgrounds and stuff like that that was
not at the same time as the SatAM one
kind of grew on me honestly just for how
insane it is uh but I kind of know that
haven't been like that many good sonic
properties I even down to the games and
like the stuff they've done had been so
desperate to get like an identity but
this one this is just the height of what
the hell at least from the trailer I'm
gonna say right now I mean it edge would
be kind of funny or if this was a good
move he liked that with just how would
they do it how would they just blow
everybody's socks off but but I don't
know I have not seen the movie and none
of us have we don't know Wow IIIi don't
even know why I'm really doing a video
it's just one of those things where it's
like I so rarely have a reaction to a
trailer this strong where it was so
awful I got excited
kind of like the room excited I don't
there's trailers too bad movies are
meant to look bad or like lame trailers
or trailers are just forgettable or
stood but I mean this was just like
remember when Coolio was upset that
Weird Al Yankovic did a parody of
gangsta's paradise because he thought
the song was too serious he was saving
it for Sonic the Hedgehog he was like
nah man no I need a blue hedgehog
running around with James Marsden like
like hop two and I need Jim Carrey and
they're not being funny I mean a bunch
of like catch phrase it that that's what
the song is about so it's about
gangsta's paradise sonic you got him
look man if that came on at first I'm
like okay that's got to be like just a
few second thing like always and that
just weird that they played
song for a second it's everything I've
heard about this movie getting back to
well saying before everything I've heard
about this movie
I just got heard in passing her in the
back from maybe I saw an internet
article or like some sort of something
online about but it's like to internet I
believe on the Internet uh and I part of
me just in the back of my head even if I
saw it on like IMDB I was like yep but
that's not really happening that's Jim
Carrey's not really gonna be in it it's
not gonna take place in modern day it's
that's not what he looks like that
leaked picture they came out that that
was the one I was like that's so not
real that is so clearly poorly
photoshopped hey you can replace Sonic
with anything and it could be anything
like this kind of setup like you could
put it could be hop to just say you know
the Easter Bunny's back and then in Jays
Martin's a cop that'd be news but it
didn't work but now he eats this magic
carrot and he has to run really fast I
mean this could be love this could be
the roadrunner a coyote movie with Sonic
as like the roadrunner Jim Carrey's the
coyote and like you would believe it
exists now you would believe that would
be a thing Jim Carrey comes in I can't
just every reveal in this just blew my
mind like really that's happening
they're doing that and he just comes in
what's what's happening at this dude man
what happens I don't know I guess he was
always I mean honestly looking back I
guess he was kind of hitting this up and
down and stuff like that I mean he
always gives it his all you can never
say he's half-assing sometimes it gives
too much I can man the moon and stuff
but yeah it's like man I mean they just
hold out like we got Jim Carrey here he
is and they just hold on him doing these
routines that are just dying such slow
painful deaths I mean they're just not
going anywhere and he looks nothing like
Robotnik until the end and you know
that's what's gonna be is gonna be like
the end of the movie
here he suddenly looks like that's gonna
be like the Street Fighter movie we're
just like oh yeah Blanca he's um
gonna be in the bag somewhere always
green for a minute at the end there
nailed it so you know that's what it's
gonna be uh nobody I think once Sonic in
the everyday world
I mean Sonic's not the cool thing about
Sonic is that you know obviously he's
very fast he's got kind of this attitude
to him you know but he's very nineties
you know so it's like the only way this
movie could work this idea could even
work the only way you might be in that
sonic movie could work at all is if you
get Lord and Miller and I you get the
guys who do like the lego movie and into
the spider-verse and we're gonna do a
good solo movie until Disney it's like
no we need to be like Sonic the Hedgehog
so this is like the only way it could
work but but they're not doing that
they're doing like every family film
that we've seen over and over
but they're doing it to such a
beautifully not even attempting to be
good way yeah I mean I okay I should say
it cuz you know a lot of people worked
hard on this movie I know that I know
movies are hard to make that's why I
hate crapping on a trailer because
that's a trailer maybe it's good but
what but it looks like such an amazing
bad like I'm legit excited for this
movie so it's weird how Sonic is always
kind of actually no it's not I was gonna
say it's weird how Sonic always comes
back and like I comment died either on a
show or something like that but it's
like they don't just constantly make bad
the Sonic things sadly uh you know I
like the original games and everything
the designs of them especially are just
so great I mean you do not see designs
like that in games back then especially
but like yeah this they just couldn't
figure out what to do with them so now
we have this movie that really doesn't
know what to do with them and they're
just I don't know I I had a ball
watching this trailer now no pun
intended but I had a real fun time
watching it and
legit excited to see this movie because
it just looks so crazy so missing the
mark I don't know this could be like
another Street Fighter movie this could
be Street Fighter we can get Street
Fighter I don't be bike Street fire
sucks yeah but it's so beautifully
sucked we could have Jim Carrey could be
like our ral juli as m.bison you know
I mean our James Marsden could er I
don't know it just you gotta go see it
just I don't know I feel like we all we
owe a Trey weave is terrible just the
dignity the respect to go and check it
out to see if it's really that bad
I'm really hoping it is cuz just hearing
gangsta's paradise played throughout
that whole thing while there's just this
hideous porcupine just runs against
these actors they're just looking at
nothing the whole time trying to tell a
joke from like the 1990s and it's just
it's phenomenal it's beautiful so I'm
not upset this trailer I'm you know it's
one of those things where it's I guess
it's kind of like go big or go home and
with this movie I let you got a real
friggin genius behind it that really
knows how to take this material and turn
it into something which it can't be done
but it's very tricky like I said this
would be liking it to the spiders or
lego movie or something like that you're
you're not gonna get a good sonic movie
I mean all the casting choices
everything they should have been your
big hint but it just looks so
spectacularly terrible that I'm
legitimately kind of happy I'm giddy
I'm like giddy over that trailer and I'm
I guess one of the reasons I'm making
this video is like I'm sure I haven't
seen like a ton I just type in sonic
trailer I see it has like Apogee leave
you isn't a million down votes and stuff
like that but I mean like it is anyone
having as good a time as I am I guess
that's why I'm making this video I just
want to know because it just it filled
me with so much joy and it's like that's
kinda what a movie supposed to do and so
I'm hoping the movie is just as
ridiculous as that trailer I hope it's
just as big a letdown
cuz weirdly enough being that big a
letdown is what I'm hyped for it it's
like a total contradiction but that's
what I'm excited for
yeah man and poor james marsden your
good actor man what are you doing
yeah Westworld I don't know yet it
chanted you're good you got you deserve
better uh I you know I again shouldn't
say maybe you'll be great you know that
missile scene was actually kind of cool
I like we takes the missiles and he kind
of plays them I mean I don't recall him
going that fast but I'm sure like he
takes whatever any of those rings or
something like that um and thank you by
the way to the people that found the old
I was in one be Sonic fan movies and
just for fun when I was there like we
did like this Robotnik blooper reel
thing where it's like I'm Joseph Ezra
but I'm like auditioning for Robotnik is
what I was heavier to so I kind of
really like him and now that I'm now
that I have a clean shave that it's like
I could have been Robotnik God probably
more convincing than Jim Carrey would
have but yeah but but that barely has
been resurfacing like you know when this
is a better Robotnik the actual movie so
but yeah it's one of those things where
it's like I'm just wondering if there's
anybody out there who's as pumped
legitimately hyped to see this movie as
much as I am cuz that trailer was just
so special it was just I don't know we
don't we see bad trailers for good
movies or bad movies or whatever you
know but we see bad trailer I mean
they're they're not this beautifully bad
and I really think that needs to be
respected on some sort of strange level
whether they were whether some poor
person is just like oh my god how do I
make this good this is the best I can do
or Studios like nope hit these notes
what do we have the rights to gangster's
paradise put that in there and you know
or if it's someone that's really trying
to pour their heart into this trailer I
don't know but they really made
something beautiful and
I really think more people got to
acknowledge that a gal acknowledged how
beautifully bad this is so um by the way
I don't know if Coolio owns the rice to
gauge to fair if it sounds like I'm
really trying to give him crap it's like
I I don't even know if he owns the
rights who knows but it's like what
other things so it's just like just
knowing the history even weird I'll also
get along too so don't don't go after
cuz people might they might just see
that movie what are you doing having a
song in there and stuff but it's like a
lot of music and stuff don't even like
you don't want the rights to it at the
time or something I don't know it's a
whole thing but like ya know it's one of
those things where it's just like I'm
wondering if anyone else got as much joy
as I did so I guess that's the reason I
make it just saying well there's a lot
of hate out there a lot of anger there's
also this way you could look at it and
I'm telling you I'm getting my ticket I
don't give a crap what the reviews say I
am seeing this movie I will be like not
first in line but the maybe first in
line unlike the second day at the dollar
theatre I am so gonna see this movie I'm
legit really excited for it so so like I
said just with all the anger being
thrown if you're a die-hard Sonic fan
you should be used to this by now anyway
they've just so many bad things have
sadly happened to this character you're
not gonna get your SatAM movie anytime
soon and sadly uh as cool as that would
be I'd love to see like a CG Sonic like
actual fully CG Sonic I think that could
be fun and get some good writers in
there but but like for a good Primo bad
looking Sonic movie that this just looks
amazing my biggest fear is that it's
gonna be boring that's always like the
big fear of like movies but from the
trailer it just doesn't look like it
anyway that plays gangsta's Paradise to
Sonic he's not gonna make a boring movie
so yeah that's that's about it I'm sorry
I know this video was weird
uh I mean people do V logs and stuff all
the time it's just like I was just legit
excited for this
this part of this trailer and like I've
watched it like three times it's like
the first trailer in awhile I've watched
three times because I just don't have
time to watch you know a lot of trailers
aim where I watch it once and then get
my thought go to work whatever but I I
felt like I had to watch this a couple
times so uh yeah that's about it enjoy
the art of this beautiful trailer we'll
see how it is maybe it'll be good
it looks unlikely but who knows and yeah
I guess I'll just review when it comes
out magaz I definitely see in this movie
that's about it and I'll talk to you
later
take care
you